the Joe Rogan experience man that was
all the rage because I'm from outside of
Charlotte it was a Tammy Faye Baker Jim
Baker just had to be shut down he was
selling so in debate coronavirus [ __ ] he
had a fake coronavirus thing that
apparently oh really he got busted for
they told him to stop stop selling that
yeah yeah man there it is Missouri
Attorney General sues Jim Baker over
misleading coronavirus cure claims oh
that just came out bro that's what he
looks like now looks great ah yeah he
looks great is the best he's looked in
years oh he was selling it for on his
website totally eliminate it kills it
deactivates it so it said I love my guys
like I love you guys
go to prison for being shady and they're
like not stopping look at that the
product is to a hundred and twenty-five
dollars in the show's website so he's
saying he's got a $125 cure for the
corona virus it does not exist I was
like drink this hand sanitizer when you
throw up that's the demon coming out of
you I didn't know he was still uh
wheeling and dealing like so Whelan
preachin um I think yes yeah I think you
show well he's out there rocking it oh
he does the Jim the jim bakker show POW
shout out to the jim bakker show yeah
North Carolina
I don't know imagine if it really did
have he really didn't have the Cure and
we were mocking I know he's like it was
like what a scientist it lives in the
woods and he brought the guy and the guy
had the cure or the figure and it worked
but no one else News he's he can't get
[ __ ] over by the FDA so he's just
gonna sell it from his website yeah sold
it for a deal with Jim Baker becomes the
king in the world he's the only one left
everyone else is like we don't have the
cure we don't have a vaccine it's just
him and his believers yeah right we'll
find out tune in folks
[Applause]